(soft music)
- Making drawings on land,
on quite a large scale
is something people have been doing
for thousands of years.
I'm Simon Beck and I make
drawings in the snow.
(wind blowing)
It started as a bit of fun
but gradually it's taken over my life.
(panting)
A ballpark estimate of footsteps,
about 5,000 steps in an hour.
(pulsing music)
A big drawing,
two hours measuring, eight hours work.
(snow crunching)
You're looking at 40,000 steps.
(chiming music)
I started doing it as
an easier alternative
to hiking up the mountain
when I wanted some exercise.
You start with a drawing
on a piece of paper,
or else a drawing in your mind.
Just treating it being like
an orienteering touring map.
You're just going a certain distance
in a certain direction,
determining distances by counting paces.
It's a very physical exercise.
It's equivalent to a long
day's walk in the hills
when you make one of these big drawings.
I'm just about the only
person in the world
doing anything like it.